bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur social gosses dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui on va parler d'un sujet
d'actualité puisque on va parler des
sondages d'opinion alors déjà un sondage
opinion qu'est ce que c'est c'est une
technique ddt enquête visant à diffuser
un questionnaire auprès d'un échantillon
d'individus qui sont représentatifs
d'une population mer ou de ce qu'on
appelle également une population cible
par exemple je veux savoir la part de
jeunes de banlieues qui votent fn un
rassemblement national pardon
donc je vais prendre un échantillon
d'individus qui sont jeunes donc je
détermine ce que ça veut dire être
jeunes qui vivent dans la banlieue selon
ce que j'ai déterminé comme étant la
banlieue et je leur demande s'ils votent
fn et donc j'ai pour résultat une part
de jeunes qui votent fn ou pas qui sont
selon moi représentatif des jeunes de
banlieue donc ça c'était pour la
définition du sondage d'opinion déjà
vous me voyez venir avec mes gros sabots
sur les éléments qui sont un peu
problématique
en effet le problème avec les sondages
d'opinion c'est tout simplement qu'on
érige en objectivité en informations
véridiques totalement objectif
voilà qu'on prend pour acquis des
résultats qui en fait sont extrêmement
subjectif et savait dès aujourd'hui elle
va vous permettre de repenser à la fois
comment sont faits les sondages mais
également ce que ces sondages révèlent
de l'état de notre démocratie
alors le premier point que je voudrais
aborder avec vous c'est le fait que les
sondages se base sur une société
artificiel pourquoi est ce que les
sondages créer une société artificielle
déjà puisque les sondages créer des
catégories au sein de la population et
ces catégories sont par essence
artificielle puisque la société n'est
pas catégorisé par elle même donc venir
essayer de créer construire des
catégories pour en fait enserrée la
population c'est quelque chose qui
forcément change un peu la perception du
réel est en fait le sondage construit
une population
si on revient sur ce que je disais pour
le vote fn je vais y arriver
le vote rassemblement national on va
dire le vote d'extrême droite pour le
vote d'extrême droite
parmi les jeunes des banlieues ça
implique déjà
définir ce que c'est que d'être jeunes
est-ce que c'est moins de 18 ans mais
dans ce cas là on vote pas est-ce que
c'est jusqu'à 25 ans mais pourquoi 25
ans à 25 ans il ya des gens qui
travaillent déjà depuis dix ans et en a
qui sortent à peine des études
voilà déjà qu'est ce que c'est que
d'être jeune est ce qu'on va apprendre
une du coup un critère d'âge est ce
qu'on va apprendre plutôt un critère de
d'activité professionnelle
est-ce qu'on va prendre un critère de
jeu vie en dehors de mon foyer familial
voilà il ya plein de choses différentes
qui peuvent coexister ici la deuxième
chose ça va être le critère donc du vote
sauf que évidemment en france il est
interdit de vérifier le butin de voeux
d'une personne c'est totalement anonyme
donc on va se baser sur des déclarations
donc là encore il y à un billet puisque
il ya des personnes qui mentent killer
aussi pas envie de révéler leur vote
et c est le dernier critère et non pas
des moindres c'est le quota de la
banlieue donc pour vous montrer que
vraiment on crée des catégories
artificiel c'est que 1 la banlieue
parisienne vu que c'est souvent de ça
qu'on parle ça peut autant être un homme
bourgeois blanc très aisés qui vit à
versailles ou à rueil malmaison autant
que ça peut être une personne
défavorisée mères-célibataires en galère
tout ça dans une un quartier un peu
craignos bref ça va totalement dans
l'extrême à l'autre la banlieue n'existe
pas puisque la banlieue ne veut rien
dire
on peut à la banlieue d'un point de vue
géographique c'est à dire toute la
sphère géographique et soul influence de
la capitale avec des gens qui des
migrations pendulaires des gens donc ils
se déplacent pour le travail etc mais
crée la banlieue en tant que groupe les
quantités de personnes qui vont être
sondés par la suite ça fait pas trop de
chance ou alors ça aurait un sens
peut-être si on posait des questions sur
les transports pour se rendre à paris et
la part de banlieusards qui travaille à
paris par exemple ça oui est ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que au delà de
créer des catégories qui sont totalement
artificielle le sondage empêche aussi
d'effectuer les croisements qui sont
nécessaires à toute analyse sociologique
c'est à dire que une personne n'est pas
défini que par le fait que les jeunes
tout comme une personne n'est pas défini
que par le fait qu'elle habite en
banlieue on l'a bien vu
mon exemple tout ça pour vous dire que
les sondages d'opinion s'appuie sur
cette idée d'un individu statistiques
qui correspond à un ou deux critères qui
ont été mis en place mais qu'en fait cet
individu statistiques et les totalement
détaché de son contexte social en termes
de couleur de peau d'ethnicité de
religion de lieux dans lequel elle vit
de situations sociales pauvres riches
classes moyennes et ces deux actifs ou
pas actif en étude
enfin bref il nous manque trop
d'informations pour en fait choisir
seulement un secrétaire ou deux critères
pour effectuer un panel bah c'est pas
suffisant alors le deuxième élément que
je voudrais porter à votre attention
c'est le fait que les sondages d'opinion
s'appuie sur le présupposé que toutes
les opinions se valent
quand j'ai ça c'est à dire que en fait
un sondage reposent sur l'idée que
chaque individu a une opinion et qu'ils
l'expriment et qu'après on agrège toutes
ses opinions et que ça nous forment un
panel avec des résultats qu'on analyse
etc
sauf que toutes les paroles ne se valent
pas en fait ça paraît tout à mon déjà
absurde de 6,10 à pouvoir interroger des
gens sur potentiellement des questions
qui ne se sont jamais posé par exemple
demain qu'elle vient me voir me demande
ce que je pense des impacts du brésil
sur la politique de pêche
autant vous dire que je n'en sais rien
en fait c'est pas quelque chose sur
lequel je me suis documenté j'ai pas
suivi je n'ai pas conscience des enjeux
que ça par contre un pêcheur des
syndicats la wii eux ça les concerne
directement mais alors moi j'en ai
aucune idée
du coup il ya quand même ce truc ou en
fait tout le monde n'a pas forcément une
opinion tout simplement
et enfin le sondage d'opinion il va
partir du principe que tout le monde a
une opinion sur tout et ça bah c'est pas
vrai en fait et c'est pas une question
d'être intelligent ou pas intelligent
c'est juste que on n'a pas forcément une
opinion sur tout et on a aussi pas
forcément les moyens d'avoir une opinion
sur tout et du coup ça entraîne un
deuxième problème qui est que comme on a
vraiment cette logique de un individu
égale une opinion dans les sondages et
bien en fait il n'ya pas de distinction
entre les personnes concernées qui voit
là vraiment par exemple on demande
l'avis des personnes sur une loi et bien
on va pas faire la distinction entre les
personnes qui seront directement
impactés par le passage de cette loi
versus les gens qui juste donnent leur
avis et qui
d'être non plus ne savent pas vraiment
grand-chose ont un avis partisans plus
parce qu'ils suivent la position de
quelqu'un d'autre que vraiment leur avis
avant par exemple si on
on fait un sondage de main sur la pma
donc l'accès à la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les femmes
lesbiennes et que demain on fait un
sondage et on se dit qu'on veut savoir
pour toute la france dont comprend des
personnages issus de catégories
socioprofessionnelles différentes et ces
deux territoires différents et on leur
demande etes-vous pour ou contre la paix
m
eh bien on va voir un résultat qui est
assez inquiétant puisque au final on
demande l'avis à tout le monde mais la
vie d'une personne que ça pour qui ça ne
va rien changer à sa vie vaut autant que
la vie d'une femme lesbienne qui a envie
d'avoir un enfant
c'est quand même un petit peu
particulier du coup il n'y a pas de
distinction entre les personnes
interrogées qu'elles soient concernés ou
pas qu'elle soit informée
ou pas et là aussi on a un problème
c'est à dire que les sondages d'opinion
ivoire a tendance à décridibiliser ou à
un visibiliser du moins les voix
militante
c'est à dire qu'il ya plein
d'organisations militantes ou du moins
des collectifs des syndicats qui sont
extrêmement bien renseigné sur certains
sujets qui freinent des positions qui
sont pas en plus forcément des histoires
de politique vraiment on va dire des
opinions qui sont nuancés qui sont au
plus proche de la réalité
et au final on oublie ces voix-là au
bénéfice d'une opinion publique
donc au final quand on suppose en fait
que toutes les opinions se valent on a
un espèce de cumul d'opinion qui n'ont
pas du tout la même force réelle et donc
on en arrive à un résultat de sondage
d'opinion qui est un artefact dépourvu
de sens je vous un peu montré les deux
plus grandes problème dans la manière
dont on fait le sondage d'opinion est en
fait dans la manière dont on crée
l'opinion publique puisque au final
c'est ça dont on parle
la fabrique de l'opinion publique c'est
quelque chose qui est lié à ce que
bourdieu appelait les faits de consensus
et je vais vous expliquer tout ça tout y
est
alors ce que nous dit bourdieu c'est que
le simple fait que des instituts de
sondages viennent poser la même question
à beaucoup de gens vivent dans un
échantillon c'est déjà un problème reste
qui veut dire c'est que y'a comme un
accord sur les questions qui méritent
d'être posées qui sont en fait à
l'agenda politique et sociale donc là où
la recherche se saisit d'enjeux de
société mais qui n'ont pas forcément à
l'agenda politique c'est à dire que
c'est pas le sujet dont tout le monde
parle en ce moment
c'est pas un sujet qu'on va apprendre
parce qu'il ya une volonté de le mettre
sur le devant de la scène etc
les sondages d'opinion en plus cette
attitude de répondre soit disant à une
demande sociale par rapport à un
événement d'actualité par rapport à une
volonté politique à une nouvelle réforme
qui aurait été mise en place et c'est
donc certes c'est intéressant d'avoir
des résultats de sondages sur des
questions en cours mais le problème
c'est que la façon dont les questions
sont posées émane d'une volonté
politique d'un agenda politique et donc
en fait ça ne laisse pas de place à
l'émergence de questions qui
n'intéressent pas les dirigeants et qui
pourtant peuvent être la réalité de
beaucoup de gens et c'est là où la
recherche à une approche totalement
différente mais voilà un sondage
il faut aussi se dire que les questions
qui sont posées elles sont pas posées
par hasard elles sont forcément comme
toute question subjective et voilà le
fait par exemple que en effet un sondage
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez c'est
un sondage qui était sur les tenues des
lycéennes
alors à ce moment là il y avait en fait
des manifestations dans les lycées de
jeunes femmes qui dénonçait le sexisme
et la sexualisation de leur corps alors
qu'elles sont lycéennes qu'elles sont
mineures voilà par des personnels de
l'éducation nationale est en fait ce
sondage est là pris un tout autre aspect
c'est à dire que les questions qui
étaient posées c'était est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre le port du cros
octobre à l'école pour contre un
décolleté mais en fait c'était pas ça le
sujet de base ces jeunes filles elles
sont venues se mobiliser pour dénoncer
des actes de sexualisation et al'inverse
ce sondage il venait poser des questions
qui paraissait tout à fait logique et
qui n'ont jamais été des revendications
de ces jeunes filles en fait et dont il
n'y a pas de place pour ce que je sais
pour les gays pour la voile à
l'émergence de nouvelles questions et
c'est quelque chose qui se rapproche des
théories black féministe par exemple et
en plus ces questions au delà d'être à
l'agenda politique et sociale il ya
quand même c'est fait que les sondages
d'opinion se fonde sur des années
quantitative donc on va voir des
questions fermées qui ne laisse pas en
fait de possibilités de réponse
alternative ou plus complexes
ça va être oui non entre les deux
parfois il va falloir une justification
mais elles sont très rarement analysé
enfin il va y avoir cinq propositions
une échelle de 1 à 10 mais en fait ça ne
dit rien des motivations concrète de la
personne ça ne dit rien de pourquoi ce
moment là elle répond comme tel est ce
que c'est parce que j'ai un ami qui m'a
convaincu l'autre jour quand on en a
discuté mais c'est demain je me reposer
la même question les bâches dans la vie
différents est-ce que vous aidera à me
demander si je suis en accord avec la
politique d' emmanuel macron mais je
sais même pas de quelle politique on est
en train de parler voilà il peut y avoir
en fait le plein de formes de questions
fermées qui sont totalement absurde
quand on y pense parce que si elle était
tournée dans un autre sens si elle était
amenée différemment dans un autre
contexte et bien dans les têtes répondu
linverse est d'ailleurs un autre
problème avec ça
c'est le fait que les sondages d'opinion
ne prennent quasiment jamais en compte
la non réponse aux questions c'est un
peu en fait l'équivalent du vote blanc
ou du vote tenu dans les élections c'est
le fait que par exemple si je sais pas
30% des personnes ont un avis positif à
la question qui est posée mais que
derrière 40 % n'ont pas répondu et les
autres on a une réponse négative
eh bien on ne va pas analyser ce 40% des
personnes qui n'ont pas répondu et
surtout on ne va pas chercher à
comprendre pourquoi ces personnes n'ont
pas répondu alors que souvent il est là
le problème est surtout que là ça va
être le chiffre majoritaire donc c'est
important de comprendre pourquoi et la
balle enquête elle s'arrête ici pour le
sondage d'opinion et on va juste
regarder les chiffres restent en de
personnes qui ont répondu et du coup le
fait de ne pas prendre en compte les non
réponses au sondage
eh bien ça donne cet effet de consensus
dont parlait bourdieu qui est l'idée que
l'opinion publique s'est exprimé d'une
même voix ou alors est très polarisé
entre deux réponses donc bref tout ce
que je vous ai
jusque là vous montrent que l'opinion
publique n'existe pas comme un mezze
bourdieu et surtout que les sondages
participe à la fabrique de l'opinion
publique et pour le pouvoir en place
pour les dirigeants et bien l'opinion
publique c'est inversement un outil très
intéressant
bon dieu dit d'ailleurs que comme les
rois pouvait dire dieu est avec moi et
bien les dirigeants aujourd'hui 10
l'opinion publique est avec moi là je
vous ai un peu montré tous les traits
négatifs des sondages d'opinion les deux
mois toutes les limites des pratiques
mises en place pour faire des sondages
d'opinion et donc la question suivante
ça va être
et bien que faire alors que faire pour
que les sondages d'opinion soient un peu
plus juste un peu plus proche de la
réalité qu'ils entendent montrer
eh bien on peut tout simplement inspiré
de dispositifs issus des sciences
sociales et notamment de la sociologie
alors la première chose qu'on peut
utiliser assez facilement c'est la
question fit la question filtre c'est
une question qu'on pose à l'enquêté qui
permet à l'enquêteur ou chercheurs
d'évaluer le degré d'intérêt et
d'implication et de connaissance de la
personne pour le sujet dont on est en
train de parler donc ça éviterait en
fait c'était fait de toutes les opinions
se valent
la deuxième chose qui pourrait être mis
en place c'est tout simplement de
valoriser les questions ouvertes aux
questions fermées
c'est à dire de mettre en place une
méthode de recherche qualitative par
opposition aux méthodes de recherche
quantitative
alors évidemment le grand problème qui
se pose ici c'est tout simplement que
les approches qualitatives demande
beaucoup plus de temps d'investissement
et de conscience de la complexité des
relations sociales etc perçu l approche
quantitative qui forcément sera un peu
plus manichéenne mais aussi beaucoup
plus facile à exploiter
donc pour répondre rapidement les
demandes politiques pour publier des
résultats un peu chocs et cetera
et bah ça va tout simplement plus vite
avec des chiffres une profession qui est
assez intéressant décliné hier de
bourdieu c'est de mesurer uniquement
l'opinion mobilisés par l'enjeu en
question donc ce à dire qu on va
consulter pour un sondage d'opinion que
les bassins qui vont être directement
impactés par la décision ou les
personnes qui ont un avis déjà forgé un
parce qu'ils sont militants qu'ils ont
une organisation politique et cetera
spécifique à ce sujet c'est un peu comme
si pour en fait poser la question êtes
vous pour ou contre le fait d'encadrer
la fin de vie donc l'euthanasie au lieu
de poser la question à toute la société
où évidemment il y en avoir une
en fait une réaction peu de recul de
bannans on va pas aider jean as tu es
bien dans ce cas là on interrogeait
uniquement les personnes qui songent à
la fin de vie des chercheurs et des
médecins spécialisés sur les sujets de
bioéthique etc et des associations qui
encadrent des personnes qui veulent
accompagner dans leur fin de vie et nos
forcément on aurait des résultats tout à
fait différent puisqu'on aurait un avis
en quelque sorte d'expert et de
participer concerné c'est maintenant le
problème avec la proposition de bourdieu
sait déjà qu'il ya des limites
techniques à la mise en place de ce
genre d' enquête
tout simplement parce que là pour la fin
de vie c'est assez facile aurillac sorte
puisque on a des acteurs qui sont
identifiés par contre sûr de faire une
enquête sur la perception des violences
policières par les populations noires en
ile de france
bah forcément ce sera un peu plus embêté
parce que en france lé recensement
ethnique religieux et cetera sont
interdits donc il ya toute une
population qu'on n'arriverait pas à
cadrer en fait donc ça n'est pas
toujours possible techniquement et la
deuxième critique qu'on peut faire à
propulsion de broc dieu sait quand même
qu'il ait un côté un peu essentialiste à
tout ça en effet on ne peut pas présumer
d'une opinion donc évidemment quand il
ya des organisations déjà toute faite et
cetera
c'est bien mais en fait on va toujours
laisser des gens sur le côté et surtout
sur des sujets où il n'y a pas forcément
cette ce cadre politique et d' expertise
et bien on peut pas vraiment savoir
présupposés ça implique que du coup on
consulte urech un certain site de
personnes alors qu'en fait pas qu'est ce
qu'on en sait qu'un autre type de
personne à part un avis sur la question
voilà la dernière proposition qu'on veut
faire à partir des sciences sociales
pour améliorer les sondages d'opinion
c'est un peu une utopie et c'est le
modèle délibératif alors le modèle
délibératif c'est un peu ce qu'on a
rencontrés avec la convention citoyenne
sur le climat c'est le fait de convoquer
des citoyens qui sont issus de milieux
sociaux différents
deux classes sociales différentes deux
secteurs d'activité différents etc etc
c'est de les réunir de les consulter sur
une question puis de leur faire avoir
accès à toute l'information possible à
tous les experts tous les lits
et sera disponible puis de leur poser la
question vaut l'appareil de boussens un
avis argumenté qui sera ensuite pris
comme base de l'opinion publique
informés en quelque sorte ça rentre un
peu dans la composition de bloomer de
considérer qu'il faut faire les enquêtes
auprès d'un public et non pas auprès des
masses ont fait de choisir un public
donc un panel mais de lui de l'informer
sur le sujet de l'impliquer dans le
processus donnera un avis plus
représentatif au final sur le rhin la
vie informer tout ça c'est une utopie
puisque évidemment on ne peut pas faire
ça avec tous les sujets et surtout il
est absolument de volonté politique de
le faire déjà et surtout qu'est ce qui
nous dit que derrière l'été les gens
pourront suivre tout ça bref voilà en
tout cas ça c'est le modèle délibératif
et je vous laisse réfléchir à ce que
vous en pensez
donc pour conclure ce que l'on peut
retenir de cette vidéo c'est que les
sondages ne sont pas à prendre au pied
de la lettre qu'il ya toujours des
nuances à apporter votre nom bien cette
phrase de bourdieu l'opinion publique
n'existe pas il a trop de complexité
trop de façon de savoir de nuances et
c'est l'opinion publique n'existe pas et
elle ne devrait pas être utilisé comme
un argument par les dirigeants alors
cette vidéo sur les sondages d'opinion
c'était l'occasion pour moi de vous
montrer comment la sociologie pu
éclairer un débat mais c'était aussi
l'occasion de vous montrer que en
réfléchissant aux sauvages les pignons
ont le plus chiant fait à quelque chose
de bien plus grands qui est l'état de
notre démocratie actuelle si cette vidéo
vous a plu ou si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire a
laissé un petit j'aime à vous abonner à
partager un succès instagram
bref à faire vivre sociaux boss merci à
tous de me suivre et je vous retrouverai
vide pour une nouvelle vidéo sur ça
c'est le buzz
[Musique]